my name is jonas rasmussen and i'm the
director of flee an animated documentary
about a friend of mine who i met when i
was 15 and a physical fight going from
afghanistan to denmark
but it's even more so about managing
a man who's had to flee himself all his
life when he was a young man in
afghanistan he couldn't be openly gay so
he kind of had to hide that away and
then he arrived in denmark and also he
had to hide his past and also it's a
story about memory and trauma
the scene we're about to go into is from
the end of the film and at this point he
came out with his story about his past
he told the story about how he came from
kenneth denmark and just afterwards now
he has to tell his family about
him being gay and they accept him all of
a sudden everything is out and so the
celebration at the gay bar is really
about him finally being in a place in
the world where he can be who he is you
know with his sexuality but also with
his past
medicine
okay
[Music]
so far
so this is a good sequence where i mean
is asking for medicine for being gay you
know he didn't see it as a disease but
he thought it was something that you
could cure and actually i mean was
really embarrassed about this part in
the film and asked me if that needed to
be in there so we had a long
conversation about that because i
thought it was so important to have that
in there because to kind of really
understand where he came from and and
how suppressed his sexuality was
yeah the lady who he's talking to works
at this assam center here the voice is
actually made by my wife
she was right next to me so i asked her
she could like to do the lines and and
actually kind of look at look alike as
well
so the animation style we chose for flea
was really being as authentic as
possible so i it's really inspired by
the landscapes from just around the area
where i grew up we recognized the fields
and the farms and the hills but it was
really about trying to support his voice
really listen carefully and do a lot of
research and here it's denmark close to
my hometown we did like a big art bible
of the wood references from different uh
visual artists so one was edward harbor
there's this certain sense of solitude
in his images that we really wanted to
have in there because a main story is
really a story about uh solitude as well
about loneliness about not being able to
be honest and we felt that you know in
the hopper paintings that there is a
sense of solitude
[Music]
at some point i would have to tell my
family and
and he was quite certain that they
wouldn't be able to accept it because it
wasn't acceptable in afghanistan in
and in the culture in general
so this sequence really plays on you
know his own prejudice against his own
family and i think most other people's
prayers against how gay people are
received in muslim families and
countries and i really wanted to have
that in there you know the sense of okay
but this is not going to go well
we work in this software in animation
that's called shotgun so every shot has
a number and a name and then the
animation director the art director and
me we would kind of write what's going
on in every shot so
in a shot like this one i would kind of
ride we had a family setting it's the
first time they're together for years
and we should feel kind of the
comfort of him be with his family but
also
quite fast feel that he's a nerd with
his older brother here he's teasing and
and here
i mean is afraid and annoyed at the same
time
and then the animation dirt could use
that for the direction for the animators
to kind of make it look like it
so of course when we see how his brother
looks at him afterwards
he said that he he's not interested in
girls that look
is because of his fear against him it's
because of i means prejudice and and
what he thinks brother thinks and we
wanted to have that in there
in the specific scene we zoom in
he's in the car and he is realizing that
now i said it now it's goodbye i have to
live my life from now on without my
family so here we kind of decided to
have these flashbacks and he would start
to recall everything in detail using the
cinematic tools using like pull and
stretch like like really stretched time
at a time so so you feel okay now time
to stand still because this is a crucial
moment and and really using that and
feel the pressure that he was on there
um because he carried this thing around
that he was gay and he didn't think that
his family would be able to accept it so
in order to give the audience just a
little bit of sense of relief of that
sense of relief that he felt when he
finally came out and he understood that
they actually did accept him and when
amin walks down the corridor towards the
bar he himself knows that it's not a
brothel or a strip club
but we wanted to keep you know the
information that the family had accepted
him until the very last second
when i write i always listen to music
and i have different playlists often
it's non-verbal music electronic it can
be classical and different kinds of
music and as i was kind of transcribing
and working on this sequence i was into
a playlist and this that punk
song came on that song really starts
when really on the moment where he
get you get a sense of solid suit that
now he's on his own and he's kind of
saying goodbye to all the good things he
had was like all the support he had from
his family and all the good memories he
had and i just felt like a perfect fit
from the very beginning and i i've had
this kind of feeling okay but this needs
to be in there because it had this sense
of loneliness and this sequence is
really about i mean feeling all alone in
the world and this song has kind of
shift as well where it kind of turns
into more of a party song
[Music]
[Applause]
so it just felt like the perfect match
and then it was just you know the
struggle of getting the rights to use it
and i just kind of hunted down that punk
for three years i think it must have
been really annoyed at the end but in
the end they saw the clip and loved it i
think it was one of the biggest release
of making this film actually to get that
song
[Applause]
[Music]
and the ava is really inspired by some
of the gay parts we went to and
specifically one in copenhagen but also
the specific one that he went to so it's
kind of a mix of different papers but
it's it's really for me inspired by a
lot of parties we printed together and
well it gave us between the two together
and of course the bartender is a little
bit inspired by shangri-fandam because i
wanted to add his lifetime crush in
there just to kind of show that it was
okay for him to feel attractive to
someone like champagne
[Applause]
[Music]
in the very last part of this sequence
we see him disappear in a crowd and
finally he is in a place in the world
you know where he is safe he doesn't
have to flee anymore and he can be
openly gay and really concludes
the film about this guy who's had to
run away from things all of his life and
now
he can't be who he is
and that's kind of where you know the
main
theme of the film ends
the story is really about sharing and
listening and and the healing powers of
of sharing and it was just a slow
process of kind of going deeper and
deeper into this
into these memories and then of course
choosing pathways because this story
takes place through more than 30 years
so it's really about finding out okay
but what's the call of this and then
figuring out what parts of his testimony
needs to be in the film and how these
experiences have marked him for life and
then
um finding archival footage and finding
a style of animation that could support
that you know but all the time you know
in the call was
listening to the voice listening to what
was being said really listening
carefully to how we said things and make
sure that we try to support that as good
as we could
[Music]
you